it's the makers so you know these women
get to come together and you know talk
about issues that are important to us
Jada Pinkett Smith talks working with
strong women
eg sat down with the read table talk
host at the 2019 makers conference in
Los Angeles on Thursday where she opened
up about the women that helped inspire
her show my mother's been through so
much yes so much wisdom and information
to offer I've been through a lot as well
and Willow in her do you know 18 years
you know has has been through a lot for
her generation right so I just felt like
you know what is that and I'll tell you
something else I was we went through a
really tough time in my life and there
were three women that were courageous
enough to be super transparent with me
ruby dee Paul little Washington and
selma hayek okay three and they were so
transparent with me and gave it to me so
real and so wrong that those three
conversations literally changed the
trajectory of my life and then I was
like why don't we have more
conversations like this like if I had
had this conversation earlier I would
have done something different like why
aren't we talking in a way in which you
know sharing and offering ourselves in
the way that we can help each other crow
help each other have the lives that we
want and that's really what made me say
listen this is ridiculous everybody's
holding information all close to the
chest we really all have information for
each other we would just talk to each
other we would know we're not in this
game alone we're all going through the
same thing it ain't nothing unique is
not nothing different it was a concept
that I thought about years ago when I
think Willow was maybe 11 and we did it
that one Mother's Day Oh
one off we didn't one bread table
because I was like wow you know it'd be
great to see three generations of women
to sit down and have real conversation I
want to do this as a way to celebrate
motherhood and so I did it for Mother's
Day
when willow was 11 and then that was it
and then Ellen racketing came to me she
was like what do you do with this red
table because I'm looking for three
generations of women to talk and so
that's how it all got restarted again
and so I just knew that there were
people that were ready to have different
kinds of conversations and I was ready
to have those conversations mommy was
ready and so as willow for more on our
sit-down with Jada tune into et tonight
[Music]